THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. WELCOME. WE
HAVE ONE MEASURE ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS. CORTEZ.
HERE. CORTEZ. HERE. NILO. HERE.
NILO. HERE. ALAN. ARCHULETA.
HERE. ARCHULETA. HERE. BECKER.
SHAKESPEARE. SHAKESPEARE. HERE
DALLY. DODD. GONZALEZ. LIMÓN
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. HERE. NGUYEN.
NGUYEN. HERE. PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. HERE. SATO. SATO.
HERE. UMBERG. THE ASSISTANT.
NOTES THE QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. I SEE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS HERE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FONG, YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME UP
AND PRESENT YOUR BILL. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
FIRST, I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU.
YOUR CHIEF CONSULTANT AND A PRO
TEM'S OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH US
IN HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO MY
COLLEAGUES, SENATOR PORTENTINO,
FOR JOINING, AUTHORING THIS BILL
AS WELL, AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND EFFORTS ON THIS ASSEMBLY
BILL. 1038 AMENDS THE PROCESS
FOR THE CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA
TO ACQUIRE AND SELL SURPLUS
PROPERTY AND USE THE PROCEEDS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BEGINNING IN THE 1950S, CALTRANS
STARTED TO ACQUIRE PROPERTIES TO
MAKE WAY FOR THE EXTENSION OF
THE 710 FREEWAY IN THE GREATER
LOS ANGELES AREA. IN 2018, AFTER
MANY YEARS OF CONTENTION,
ALTERNATIVES TO THE FREEWAY WERE
IDENTIFIED AND THE DECISION WAS
MADE TO HALT THE PLANS FOR THE
FREEWAY EXTENSION IN 2021 AND
2022. SEVERAL BILLS WERE ENACTED
TO ESTABLISH THE PROCESSES FOR
DISPOSING OF HOMES ACQUIRED BY
CALTRANS. CONSISTENT WITH STATE
LAW, THE ROBERTI ACT, AND IN
ORDER TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA. TWO PROCESSES WERE
ESTABLISHED, ONE FOR HISTORIC
HOMES AND ONE FOR NON HISTORIC
HOMES. FOR HISTORIC HOMES, THE
CITY IS ABLE TO PURCHASE THE
HOMES FROM CALTRANS AT COST AND
SELL THE PROPERTIES AS IS AT
MARKET RATE, WITH THE PROCEEDS
FROM THE SALE OF THESE
PROPERTIES, THE CITY IS REQUIRED
TO DEVELOP OR ACQUIRE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR VERY LOW, LOW OR
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AT A
RATIO OF 3 TO 1 THREE UNITS FOR
EVERY UNIT ACQUIRED FROM
CALTRANS. FOR NON HISTORIC
HOMES, HOWEVER, THE CITY IS
REQUIRED TO REHABILITATE THE
PROPERTIES WHICH ARE UNOCCUPIED
AND UNINHABITABLE, AND EITHER
RENT OR SELL TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AT AFFORDABLE PRICES.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE HOMES
ARE IN DILAPIDATED CONDITIONS
AND NEED A LOT OF
REHABILITATION. THE CITY
COMMISSION INSPECTIONS OF THE
PROPERTIES AND RECEIVED A REPORT
INDICATING A NEED OF MORE THAN
$7 MILLION TO BRING THE HOMES UP
TO BUILDING CODES. THIS COST
WOULD MAKE IT HARD FOR THE CITY
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THE
PROPERTIES IF THEY ARE NOT
DISPOSED OF BY THE CITY OR
ANOTHER HOUSING ENTITY, THE
PROPERTIES WOULD BE SOLD THROUGH
OXYGEN AND WILL USE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK. BUT
ASSEMBLY BILL 103, DOES IT
CHANGE THE PROCESS SO THAT THE
CITY CAN DISPOSE OF NON HISTORIC
HOMES? THE SAME WAY THEY DISPOSE
OF HISTORIC HOMES? THIS WILL
ALIGN WITH THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA'S AUTHORIZATION WITH
THE CITY OF PASADENA'S
AUTHORIZATION, WHICH DOES NOT
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN HISTORIC AND
NON HISTORIC HOMES. THIS BILL
WILL ENABLE THE CITY TO SELL ALL
20 PROPERTIES OFFERED BY
CALTRANS TO MARKET RATE BUYERS.
WITH THE PROCEEDS, THE CITY WILL
BE ABLE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
THE CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA. AND
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL HAS
BEEN VETTED BY CALTRANS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS THE
HONORABLE DARIO FROMMER, OUR
FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA. AND JOINING US ALSO AT
THE DAIS IS ROXANNE DIAZ, THE
CITY'S ATTORNEY, TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WITNESSES MAY PROCEED IN
WHATEVER ORDER YOU PREFER.
YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES
EACH. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIRMAN.
DARIO FROMMER I'M A PARTNER AT
MAYER BROWN LAW FIRM. I'M
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO THE CITY OF
SOUTH PASADENA. AB 1038 IS
CRITICAL TO ADVANCING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN SOUTH PASADENA UNDER
OUR RECENTLY CERTIFIED HOUSING
ELEMENT, BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW
THE CITY TO PURCHASE AND SELL 13
DILAPIDATED, VACANT SURPLUS
PROPERTIES ON THE STATE ROUTE
710 CORRIDOR AT MARKET PRICES,
AND USE THE PROCEEDS TO FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT A 3 TO 1
RATIO. IF THIS BILL IS ENACTED,
THEN WE WILL BE ABLE TO DEVELOP
60 UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN SOUTH PASADENA. AS THE
ASSEMBLYMAN MENTIONED, THE
EXISTING LAW TREATS THE
AFFORDABLE, THE HISTORIC AND
NON-HISTORIC SURPLUS PROPERTIES
DIFFERENTLY. WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING
FOR THE BRING THEM INTO
CONFORMITY WITH WHAT THE CITY OF
PASADENA HAS, WHICH IS TO BE
ABLE TO ACQUIRE THOSE HISTORIC
AND NON HISTORIC PROPERTIES AT
THE PRICE THAT CALTRANS PAID AND
TO BE ABLE TO SELL THEM AT
MARKET RATES AND THEN USE THE
PROCEEDS TO DEVELOP OR ACQUIRE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT A 3 TO 1
RATIO. WE HAVE LOOKED AT THE
HOUSES, AS ASSEMBLYMAN SAID, WE
HIRED AN INSPECTOR TO COME IN
WHEN THE HOUSES WERE OFFERED TO
THE CITY IN 2019 AND 2022, THEY
WERE IN VERY BAD CONDITION. THE
INSPECTIONS YIELDED A REPORT
THAT THAT WAS ABOUT $7 MILLION,
MORE THAN $7 MILLION IN REPAIR
COSTS, WHICH IS DIFFICULT FOR A
CITY THE SIZE OF SOUTH PASADENA
TO SUSTAIN AND WOULD ULTIMATELY,
WE DON'T THINK ANY HOUSING
RELATED ENTITY WOULD TAKE THESE
PROPERTIES, AND THEY WOULD
THEREFORE GO TO PUBLIC AUCTION.
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
PRESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO USE
THESE RESOURCES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THE CITY
WISHES TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIKE FONG, SENATOR ANTHONY
PORTANTINO, THE CALTRANS FOLKS
AND THE HOUSE, THE COMMUNITY
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT, WHO HAVE WORKED
COLLABORATIVELY WITH US, ALONG
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
DEVELOP THIS BILL TO FIND A
SOLUTION AND MAKE SURE THESE
RESOURCES DO GO TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND DO NOT GO TO PUBLIC
AUCTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, I
THANK YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. OR IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL? IF SO,
PLEASE COME FORWARD NOW. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SEEING NONE, IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION? IF SO,
PLEASE COME FORWARD NOW. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR PORTANTINO,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND FOR
SETTING THE BILL. AND THANK YOU,
MR. FONG, FOR PROVIDING THE BILL
THAT WAS AVAILABLE TO DO THIS
VERY NECESSARY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THE MOST IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THIS IS WE'RE
CONFORMING WITH EXISTING LAW
RELATIVE TO PASADENA. AND I
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE, TO NOTE AS WELL AS IF WE
DON'T DO THIS BILL, THERE WOULD
BE A $7 MILLION LIABILITY TO
BRING HISTORIC HOMES UP TO A
SELLABLE, FORM. AND THEN THEY
WOULD NOT BE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BY ALLOWING THE CITY TO
PURCHASE THESE HOMES AT THE
ORIGINAL PRICE AND USE THE
PROCEEDS, WE'RE GOING TO GET
THREE TIMES THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO PRESERVE HISTORIC HOMES
AND BE CONSISTENT WITH THE LAW
THAT WAS PASSED FOR PASADENA.
AND SO THIS IS A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYONE AS, MR. FROMER
MENTIONED, HCD AND MR. FONG
MENTIONED HCD, THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE, EVERYONE HAS BEEN
WORKING FOR SIX MONTHS TO GET
THIS LANGUAGE TO WHERE IT IS
RIGHT NOW, AND IT'S EXCITING FOR
ME AS MY FINAL TERM IN THE
LEGISLATURE, TO NEVER HAVE TO
LOOK AT A 710 BILL AGAIN, IS
EXCITING THAT WE CAN MOVE PAST
AND GET RID OF THESE PROPERTIES,
GET THEM INTO PRIVATE OWNERSHIP,
AND LET THE CITIES DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO, WHICH IS PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THEN
PRESERVE THE HISTORIC NATURE OF
THESE HOMES. SOME OF YOU MAY NOT
KNOW, BUT ONE OF THE HISTORIC
HOMES IN THE CORRIDOR WAS JULIA
CHILD'S ACTUAL HOME THAT SHE
GREW UP IN AS ONE OF THE
HISTORIC HOMES. SO THERE'S A LOT
OF HISTORY IN THIS CORRIDOR.
THERE WAS A 70 YEAR STRUGGLE,
OVER THE FREEWAY THAT ULTIMATELY
FOLKS SAW FIT TO NOT BUILD. AND
LET'S GET THIS PROPERTY INTO
PRIVATE HANDS AND GIVE THE CITY
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO DO IT.
RIGHT. SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AS WELL,
WHEN APPROPRIATE. AND MOVE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS? SENATOR
NHIÀU? SO I UNDERSTAND THE
EFFICACY OF THE IDEA AND THE
PROPOSAL, BUT, THE PROPERTY IS
BEING SOLD BY THE STATE TO THE
CITY FOR ITS ORIGINAL PURCHASE
PRICE, NOT CURRENT MARKET VALUE.
THERE'S QUITE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO. AND THEN THE
CITY IS ABLE TO SELL THE
INCLUDED ASSETS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO SELL AT CURRENT MARKET
VALUE, THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO GET IN ON A
DEAL LIKE THAT, BUT THEY
COULDN'T BECAUSE IT WOULD BE A
GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS. SO HOW DO
WE AVOID THAT? YES. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SO ON YOUR BALANCE
SHEET, YOU HAVE TO SCORE THE $7
MILLION BECAUSE IN ORDER TO SELL
THE HOUSES, THE CITY WOULD HAVE
TO PUT $7 MILLION OF REPAIRS
INTO THOSE HOUSES TO MAKE THEM
MARKETABLE. AND SO YOU HAVE TO
PUT THAT $7 MILLION IN THE IN
THE EQUATION. SO BY DOING THIS
FORMULA, THE ULTIMATE PURCHASER
OF THE HOME WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE REPAIRS, NOT THE CITY.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THIS THAT'S
WHY THE ECONOMICS OF THIS WORK
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S GOOD FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY, WHETHER IT
WOULD BE CALTRANS OR THE CITY,
WOULD BE ON THE HOOK FOR THOSE
REPAIRS. THIS SAVES THE TAXPAYER
$7 MILLION AND PROVIDES THREE
TIMES THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS FOR THE CITY TO MAKE, IF
THAT MAKES SENSE TO YOU. AND IF
CITY ATTORNEY IF I SAID THAT.
RIGHT. I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING TO
THAT. NO, THAT IS CORRECT. THE
PURPOSE OF THE ACT IS TO, TO
MOVE FORWARD THE STATEWIDE
CONCERN OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I BELIEVE THAT IN THE BILL
ITSELF, WHEN IT WAS ADOPTED,
MADE FINDINGS WITH RESPECT TO IT
NOT BEING A GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS
BECAUSE OF THE SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, OTHERWISE,
CALTRANS WOULD HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO, WHICH FOR FUNDS
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO FIX THE UNITS AND SELL THEM.
AND SO THIS PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CITIES TO
ALONG THE CORRIDOR TO CREATE
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
ALL OF THE CONSTITUENTS IN THAT
AREA AS WELL. SO HOPEFULLY THAT
ANSWERS THE QUESTION. YEAH THANK
YOU, SENATOR NEIL. NO THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE ON
THE COMMITTEE WISHING TO ASK
QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS AND
SEEING NONE? WE DO HAVE A MOTION
THAT'S BEEN OFFERED BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO WILL GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL THE QUESTIONS AND
FOR THE DISCUSSION HERE TODAY. I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. WE WILL ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO CALL THE ROLL CALL
VOTE AT THIS TIME. THIS IS FOR
ITEM NUMBER 1AB1038. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND B REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR CORTESE. CORTESE. I
NILO. NILO I ALLEN. ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA I BECKER. BLAKE SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER I DALLEY. DODD I
DODD I GONZALEZ. LIMON. LEMON I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I NGUYEN.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I SEYARTO
UMBERG I UMBERG I. 9201 CALLS.
ALL RIGHT. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 9
TO 0. WE LEAVE THIS BILL ON CALL
UNTIL 930. AND APPEARS TO HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES
AND EVERYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
WHO CAME BEFORE US, I APPRECIATE
IT. I PROBABLY VOTED FOR.
SOMETHING I'M GOING TO CALL IT
NOT HAVING A RECESS, FOR
PURPOSES OF AUDIO VISUAL HERE.
AND WE'LL SEE IF WE GET ANY MORE
MEMBERS COMING IN. IN THE
MEANTIME, FIVE MINUTES IS AS
LONG AS WE'LL GO IN RECESS.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO CALL THE
COMMITTEE BACK TO ORDER. THE
RECESS IS NOW OVER, AND WE HAVE
BEEN HEARING SB 1038 80. I'M
SORRY, AB 1038, THE BILL IS ON
CALL. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL AGAIN AND TRY TO
CONCLUDE THE VOTE NOW. THANK
YOU, SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN, I
BECKER BECKER I DALLI GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I NGUYEN SEYARTO. 12 TO
0. ALL RIGHT. THE BILL IS OUT 12
TO 0. THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA
FOR TODAY, THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR PULLING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER. AND EVERYONE
ELSE WHO GOT THE HEARING ROOM
READY THIS MORNING FOR US, WE
ARE NOW ADJOURNED.